From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[MUSIC] Librarianship was really
an adventure for me-to find
out that there's a profession
that was dedicated to making books
and reading and knowledge
available to people.
And that just seemed ideal.
The confirmation process was really
an eye-opener for me in so many ways
because I got to meet
legislators that were committed
to not only the nation's history,
but making information available.
And that made me very
pleased that I was confirmed.
My vision for this library is very
simple: that people will realize
that they have a national
treasure and that it is part
of their heritage and everyone
can find something in the Library
of Congress, produced by
the Library of Congress,
that relates to their lives
or where they want to go.
What I hope to accomplish with
the dedicated staff of The Library
in the next ten years of the
appointment is to really make more
of the collections
accessible in various formats.
And if we can say that we have
collections in the next ten years
that have never been seen digitally
and that are used and that are tied
in with curriculums
around the country
and that people are going
to, at the end of ten years,
if people are thinking of the
Library of Congress as a go-to place
in the stratosphere, really, for
information and resource-that,
I think, would be quite
an accomplishment.